nous allons essayer mais labs et
messieurs de le juger le moins mal
possible sachant que la règle
essentielle c'est celle de lundi un
succès ce que vous avez ressenti subi
entendu ce que l'on écrit ce que l'on a
tu sais ce que vous êtes et c'est sous
le prisme de ce que vous êtes
on va juger ce temps mon intime
conviction c'est qu'il est coupable
mon intime conviction c'est que les
choses ne se passent jamais comme on les
avait imaginées
[Musique]
un apéritif pour commencer non on va
commencer avec un divorce par
consentement mutuel
[Musique]
on annonce plus de mauvaises nouvelles
est actuellement logique fait beaucoup
de tort je peux avoir vos papiers
d'identité allumée ok c'est bon c'est
pas la question de savoir si c'est un
bon coup se pose plus qu'à tromper sa
femme toi je mets tous nous unir pour
voir comment il faut que je fasse passer
des retouches
je vois tu me diras les yeux dans les
yeux tu vois je te croirais peut-être
lardons tard
le montant de votre relation fiscale ces
pages il salue mes robes téléphone
l'impasse par jour pendant 20 ans a fait
150 4000 clients
je vais écrire mes mémoires et si chacun
des clients achètent un exemplaire ça va
faire un [ __ ] de best-sellers
vous êtes sûr que voulait divorcer
g
m